apparently there is a cheater who is
just plaguing the European CS2 servers
and by plaguing I mean
shutting down entirely yes that's right
this cheater isn't just cheating in
order to circumvent valve's new vac live
infrastructure they're shutting down
servers before they can be reported look
Counter-Strike is no stranger to hacks
but CS2 was supposed to finally Deliver
Us real first party matchmaking
is that dream already dead
[Music]
in recent weeks there have been tons of
reports of cheaters in CS2 which to be
clear is in no way shape or form
surprising cheaters flock to new FPS
games like mods to a flame what is
surprising is that level 4 steam
accounts with [__] wall hacks get to
play CS2 but I a 5k hour Global who's
been playing Counter-Strike for 18 years
don't
guess I uh should have spent the last
three years grinding valorent instead of
churning out CS go content
my bad
anyway salty asides aside cheaters now
that CS2 has been out for a few months
they're infesting it and again that's to
be expected what's weird and genuinely
concerning is the extent to which
they're able to manipulate the
infrastructure just over a week ago
long-standing CS go streamer trilix
posted a clip where after being
subjected to a pretty sus wall bang he
went to report the suspect and this
happened
off
ers
[Music]
hello dear this go devs I've just played
against this guy who was obviously
cheating and he just manages he just
managed to crash the server
please fix maybe first of all can I just
say you are not only wall hacking but
crashing servers in a closed beta
designed for bug reporting
I would strongly encourage you to go
outside and just make physical contact
with a single piece of nature
second of all it's not so much that this
crayon eater was ruining lobbies but how
from what I gather the way that valve's
new vac live Fail-Safe is supposed to
work is that the second that someone
reports an account for cheating it runs
a sort of diagnostic this can result in
a Lobby being canceled straight away and
the cheater instantly banned which is
what happened in this clip that went
viral like a month ago what trilix's
cheater was doing was shutting down the
lobby before anyone could report him how
this actually works on the back end is
anyone's guess but it does seem as if he
was doing it quite frequently as he was
also in three lobbies with reputed cs go
Caster sponge suffice it to say this is
somewhat concerning mostly because of
what it could spell for the future to be
clear I am not out here prophesizing the
Doom of CS2 matchmaking the game is in
beta it's a little early to be that
alarmist or pessimistic that be being
said seeing a cheater with that level of
control or influence over a lobby at any
stage of a game's development is
definitely a little disconcerting long
time Siege lovers are no stranger to
cheaters whipping out absolutely insane
ways to wipe lobbies crash lobbies and
do whatever the [__] this is
bro bro what is this I'm not saying
Counter-Strike 2 will ever get to that
point Siege is on a special level of
stupid when it comes to cheese
what I am saying is that maybe we
shouldn't be so quick to uh to ditch the
good old-faced subscription for those
who don't know regular CS go matchmaking
has been so infested with cheaters since
basically the dawn of the game that the
communities had to rely on third-party
matchmaking services like Esa and face
it to get real matches with related
cheats but ever since CS2 was announced
and valve's new vac live infrastructure
unveiled
the community couldn't help but wonder
whether we might finally be getting a
real first party matchmaking service
it's safe to assume I think that when
CS2 does eventually come out it'll
probably come with a huge matchmaking
overhaul new seasonal ranks resets ELO
systems Etc I don't know this for a fact
but they have done it for like a literal
decade in Dota there is no reason they
can't do it in CS it also just doesn't
make sense why they put all of this
effort into developing the back Live
tech and things like subtik if they
weren't going to make it worth our while
the thing is the distrust that the
community has for Counter-Strike servers
runs deep Bro like really deep I'm not
even just talking about CS go vac has
been a certifiable meme since the early
to mid 2000s and the community's
patience has worn very thin if there is
even the slightest sign of a crack in
the foundation players will flock back
to face it like that mind you valve are
a state-of-the-art tech company and what
they lack in caring about literally
anything they make up for in super
sophisticated software I've said it
before but if valve can figure out how
to Port over whatever it is like 600
million skins from CS go to CS2 then
they can do anything including
replicating a face it or valorant grade
antigen will they
I mean it certainly seems like they are
as for whether they're successful
only time will tell it's safe to say
that the future of Counter-Strike has
probably never looked brighter and I for
one am hopeful that valve will go full
on hold my beer with CS2 and actually
turn it into all of the things that we
as a community deserve that is of course
um once we're able to actually play it
cheat in a server that matters you know
what I mean yeah yeah baby steps baby
steps yeah cheat for actual ELO in a
sweaty environment and then from there
you can like wean yourself off you know
what I mean like yeah yeah exactly
dude